[Music]
so there's two general hypotheses or
theories about the nature of time one of
them will call present ISM and present
and present ISM the notion is is that
only the present is real the past was
real the future some configuration of
the future universe will be real but for
now only the present Israel in contrast
the opposing view is called eternalism
internal ISM you have the past president
future are all equally real so that
makes the present just an arbitrary
point in time or an arbitrary moment in
time so one way to think about this is
now is to time as here is to space so in
the same sense that I happen to be here
and some viewers are out at some other
point in space and we're all comfortable
with that notion that other points in
space are equally real in eternalism you
have to be comfortable with the notion
that other moments in time are as
equally real as this moment in time and
this is just an arbitrary moment so
under that view there are other moments
so there's a continuum of moments in
time that are essentially already laid
out within the universe and that
universe in physics called the block
universe so under the block universe it
makes sense to engage in a conversation
about time travel because there's other
moments to go to not that this doesn't
speak to the issue of whether time
travel is actually pause plausible or
not it's probably not but it enables the
conversation because other moments in
time exist now under present ism we can
pretty much take the possibility of time
travel off the table because there's no
other moments to go through only the
present is real so it doesn't make sense
to ask if you can travel to moments in
time in the past or future that don't
exist now there's a class here between
neuroscience and physics so intuitively
the time time seems to be changing we
humans experience the flow of time
under a journalism it's where everything
is already laid out the flow of time is
a deep mystery because it would seem to
be that if all moments in time are
already laid out within the block
universe that the flow of time shouldn't
exist or must be an illusion so if the
flow of time if our subjective sense of
the flow of time is an illusion we have
this clash between physics and
neuroscience because the dominant theory
in physics is that we live in the block
universe and there's by an eye should be
clear there's no consensus there's no
100% agreement but the standard view in
physics is that and this comes in large
part from relativity that we live in a
journalist universe in the block
universe in which the past present
future is equally real so this raises
the question of whether we can trust our
brain to tell us that time is flowing so
I think we need to have a improved
dialogue between physics and
neuroscience here so on one hand we have
to decide is if we want to accept that
our subjective sense of the flow of time
is an objective fact about the universe
we perceive time to be flowing things
seem to be changing the past seems to be
vaporizing into into the past and the
future seems to be wide open now if it's
the case that we live in the block
universe that seems to be illusory in a
very deep sense so we have to decide if
we want to take our subjective sense of
the flow of time as an objective fact
about the universe that must be
explained by physics or in contrast is
our subjective sense of the flow of time
merely an illusion an illusion in the
deepest sense of that word because we're
perceiving something that doesn't exist
in the physical world that physics
doesn't need to explain because it
doesn't exist and the snarls
needs to address where the solution
comes from and this illusion is
presumably tightly coupled with the
problem of consciousness
[Music]